we just got some major leaks revealing
Apple's work on an Olin MacBook Air
which is a massive deal because every
MacBook for decades has always come with
an LCD display so this would be a
display Revolution especially by
including the dynamic Island however
with all good sets of news there's
always a little bit of bad news but
before I get into that I've got to talk
about the difference between LCD and
OLED with a typical LCD display which
means Liquid Crystal you have an entire
backlight as the light source that goes
through layers like the polarizing
filters the color filters and then that
comes out as colored light now there are
also LCD displays that come with local
dimming like Apple's Pro display xdr
which is very similar to an LCD display
but instead of having a full white panel
for the light it uses these small local
areas with very power powerful blue LEDs
and then the light goes through a bunch
of color mixing and shaping layers to
become what you see with a mini LED
display where you have higher contrast
ratios because parts of the display are
completely turned off and then on all
the displays instead of having a full
white backlight unit the light actually
comes from each individual organic LED
chip and the main benefit of that is
that when you have areas that are dark
or black it's actually very very dark
and black because the OLED chips
themselves are completely turned off
like you can see in this video where you
have kind of text right here but once
you zoom in you can see each individual
LED chip that's being lit up with all
these colors to create white but these
black areas are completely turned off so
you have an infinite contrast ratio that
looks amazing but on an LCD display even
when the whole image is black the
backlight is always on because it has to
be so that's why it looks very gray at
night now Apple's mini LED display helps
with that but you do have a Halo glowing
effect and the high contrast areas OLED
doesn't have any issues with that and it
can even save you battery life when
showing dark or
midges on the screen because the pixels
are off and not
power and that is why this OLED MacBook
Air is going to be so revolutionary so
let's get into this leak we just got
this leak from the elec reporting that
in OLED MacBook Air is currently in
development and Samsung display is
working on it right now so it is
definitely coming and they're even
making even better more advanced
displays for the MacBook Pro which I'll
get into in just a minute and that new
leak actually matched up to something
that Ross young said before saying that
an OLED MacBook Air is coming and it was
supposed to be launching in
2024 however we have our bad news he
just gave us an update saying that we
are going to be getting a MacBook Air
with OLED but it's going to be a little
bit smaller
13.4 inches instead of
13.6 and I'll get into why in just a
minute but the bad news is that it's not
coming until 2026
6. yes three years from now until we
finally get this OLED MacBook Air and
the question is why is this happening so
late well in my opinion I believe that
this OLED display has to come to the
MacBook Pro first and I think it's going
to be a dual stack OLED display which
I'm gonna explain but first before that
MacBook Pro I believe that the OLED iPad
Pro has to come first according to all
the leaks and the reason it makes sense
is because we have rumors saying that
the OLED panels are going to cost two to
three times more which makes sense with
a dual stack OLED that's why it's going
to be so expensive so what is a dual
stack OLED well let me explain well
first of all that dual stack OLED leak
actually matches to an old one from
November of 2021 saying that future iPad
Pro and MacBook Pro Models will have an
ultra bright double stack OLED display
and you can see on the left right here
you have a single stack but on the right
you have a tandem or dual stack with
basically the same thing stacked twice
and you can see right here increases
brightness by 1.5 to 2 times brighter
and that is extremely important for
Apple now in my opinion I believe that
all of the regular or cheaper iPad
models are getting the single stack
display while the iPad Pro and MacBook
Pro Models will get the dual stack OLED
display which will be twice as bright
which is very important because when
Apple redesigned the 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros they gave it a mini LED
display and they even explained why they
said that it allows them to reach 1600
nits of peak brightness for HDR content
which OLED at the time could not do
because OLED displays are quite a bit
dimmer however dual stack OLED
completely solves that issue with
brightness and there's no Halo low
effect like we have on the mini LED
displays so essentially these new dual
stack oleds will be the king of all
displays and now let's get into the
dynamic Island idea and why I think it's
coming to both the OLED iPad Pro and all
MacBook models with OLED displays
including the MacBook Air now going back
to the recent leak from Ross young
saying that the OLED display on the
MacBook Air is going to be 13.4 inches
the weird thing about that is that the
current MacBook Air display is
13.6 so why would Apple downgrade the
display well to figure that out we've
got to go back to the M1 MacBook Air
which had a 13.3 inch display and asked
why they put it up to a 13.6 inch well
first of all they slim the bezels all
around which added about 0.1 inches of
display space and then the additional
0.2 inches was actually added to the top
of the display just like what happened
to the 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pro Models
and that was specifically added for the
notch so that when the upper bar is
disabled when watching full screen media
you still get the same perfect aspect
ratio and scaling that you got before so
basically if apple is removing that 0.2
inches of display space that means
they're probably getting rid of the
notch on all OLED MacBook display models
but the problem with that is the webcam
where does it go because it's not going
to fit in the very slim bezels without
the notch right well no if Apple brings
the dynamic Island to all OLED MacBooks
they'll be able to easily fit the camera
and face ID sensors yes face ID on the
MacBooks by moving all of that just a
little bit lower down on the display
just like they've done on the iPhone Pro
Models with the dynamic Island which you
can see right here is a little bit lower
than it was before now you might ask why
wouldn't Apple just bring the dynamic
Island to the MacBook Pro Models right
now instead of waiting well that's
because LCD displays are very tough to
cut for example Apple had a lot of
issues with cutting a notch into the LCD
iPhone 10r display which had a lot of
quality control and display panel loss
issues so basically apple is waiting to
bring the dynamic Island to the iPad Pro
and MacBooks until the OLED displays are
ready to go now here's the final nail in
the coffin for the dynamic Island idea
and it has to do with the latest iPad
Pro which is actually missing the
landscape camera that came to the budget
iPad and the reason it doesn't have the
landscape camera is because the spot for
the camera is exactly where the wireless
charger is for the apple pencil 2 and as
you can see in this x-ray the landscape
camera would not fit between the bezel
it would have to go into the display
however by switching to the dynamic
Island the whole setup with face ID
would move down a little bit into the
display allowing enough room for Those
sensors and camera and the wireless
charger for the apple pencil 2 at the
same time essentially being the perfect
solution so if apple is going to
implement the dynamic Island on the iPad
Pro then why not bring it to the MacBook
models as well starting with all of the
OLED displays basically making it a huge
and very unique feature exclusive to
Apple with the dynamic Island being the
central hub for notifications and
everything else across all of those
products and that's what I think is
gonna happen if you completely disagree
with me let me know down in the comment
section below but if you enjoyed the
video click the circle above to
subscribe and check one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]